[Music]
we live in a time where a lot of social
conflicts are presented in moral terms
people wonder who is the perpetrator and
who is the victim here and the way we
answer that question shapes The
Narrative that emerges
once people decide who to blame how easy
is it to change their views in our
research we discovered that we can
actually flip the script in terms of who
gets blamed for long-standing conflicts
in some of our experiments we were able
to change who's being blamed by almost
30 percent
we focused on entrenched ongoing
disputes where it would be most
surprising if we could shift people's
moral judgments so we started with the
israeli-palestinian conflict
if you're an Israeli who do you blame
for the lack of a solution
provided with just two choices most
Israelis may choose to blame the
Palestinians we wondered what would
happen if people considered more options
so we asked them to divide the blame
between the Palestinians and three
different Israeli subgroups the right
wing left wing and Center blocks
other participants were given the choice
between blaming Israel or three
different Palestinian political groups
what we did is called unpacking
unpacking groups into their constituent
subgroups is something we do intuitively
all the time for example you can think
about the EU as a single entity or you
can think about Italy France Germany and
other countries within it
as it turns out unpacking changes how
people decide which groups deserve the
greater share of the blame in our study
when the Palestinian side was unpacked
into three subgroups participants
assigned about two-thirds of the blame
to it as a whole but when the Israeli
side was unpacked we saw a complete flip
now the Israeli side received two-thirds
of the blame
when people form moral judgments they
don't reason like scientists in fact
they often think like prosecutors or
defense attorneys trying to protect
their sense of moral self-regard or
avoid feelings of collective guilt when
you unpack a group you find ways to
shift or distance blame from your
specific subgroup if I as an Israeli
don't want to think that Israel is
mostly responsible for the conflict I
might say well there are subgroups
within Israeli Society who are more to
blame than others if I don't identify
with them my sense of moral self-regard
is not harmed by signing a lot of blame
to them
we also ran similar experiments on
racial tensions in the U.S and on the
gender wage Gap and found that people's
opinions on who's to blame could be
flipped there as well who's to blame for
the gender gupping wages women or men
unpacking women into white women black
women and other ethnicities LED people
to assign more blame to women and when
we unpacked men into those same racial
categories people increased the amount
of blame they signed to men
there's something else going on here a
phenomenon called Partition dependence
that's a cognitive process where people
assign more importance to a specific
category when it's broken into smaller
parts once you know what partition
dependence is you start to see it in so
many different places for example when
people are asked How likely it is that
they will die of natural causes they
give a lower estimate than when they are
asked to consider a long list of natural
causes of death knowing this insurance
sells people sometimes use a list of
potentially deadly faiths to persuade
consumers to purchase insurance plans
people are often wrong about their
intuitive belief that their moralized
views can't be shifted yet we were able
to shift them pretty significantly
through reframing the way that we asked
just one question
what we discovered in our research is a
tool that can be used in many different
ways
on the positive side Educators can use
it to engage young people in
conversations about the malleability of
social justice
the negative side politicians can use it
to pour more gasoline on the Flames of
hate in interrupt conflict
so what can you do with this if you hear
someone lamenting about how it's not
even worth their time to engage with
people across the aisle you could
mention that moral views can be
surprisingly malleable
our research shows that small changes
can have large Ripple effects you have
the power to change how people think
about important societal issues